reprendre confiance en soi faire du
sport quand on est attendent au b zitte
et c'est l'objectif de l'hôpital
pédiatrique et de rééducation de bullion
pendant trois mois des enfants surcharge
pondérale participent à leur programme
une convention de partenariat avec
l'union sportive de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines a été signée
afin que les enfants pratiquent le
tennis conseillé en cas de surcharge
pondérale l'âge faire de bullion donc il
ya 107 enfants qui sont qui peuvent être
accueillis au sein de l'hôpital de
bullion avec des hospitalisations
complètes mais aussi des séjours
notamment pour les enfants en situation
de surcharge pondérale sur un trimestre
avec un projet d'éducation thérapeutique
vraiment particulier
donc là c'est le premier jour de l'année
dont qui fait septembre à décembre mais
il y aura d'autres jeunes qui viendront
de janvier à mars et ensuite d'avril à
juin donc chaque séjour pourra
bénéficier de cette opération là les
jeunes sont regroupés chaque semaine et
pratique le tennis durant 1h30
c'est la première fois qu'on met ça en
place
ce qui est vraiment intéressant c'est
une basse et un public est complètement
différent du public qu'on a
habituellement donc pour nous c'est un
challenge de réussir à les intéresser à
l'activité
les enfants hospitalisés change de cadre
en pratiquant au sein du club de tennis
de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ils sont
emmenés en mini bus depuis l'hôpital
c'est vrai qu'on s'entendait on sort pas
beaucoup donc c'est pas mal de sortir un
peu de prendre l'air et va devenir faire
du sport autre part que dans le centre
le sport en fait c'est la plaie c'est ce
qui nous ce qu'on a besoin en fait pour
se dépenser et pour résister de prendre
du repos ces enfants en surcharge
pondérale reprennent goût au sport et
continueront en dehors du centre moi je
trouve ça très bien moi j'aime bien
faire
j'en ai fait dans mon école et bah ça me
plaît je vais peut-être poursuivre si au
niveau du tennis un projet futur socio
éducative sera mis en place cette année
proposer des cours de tennis aux
personnes à mobilité réduite